i don't give investment advice but i do
want to tell you about a high-yielding
low-risk investment that's backed by the
u.s government and is paying more than
three times the rate of a 30-year
government bond and more than 120 times
the average savings account it's called
a series i savings bond or i-bond for
short i'm going to tell you what i-bonds
are where and how to get them and why in
a world where seemingly everyone is
looking for safe investments with high
returns you've probably never heard of
them
let's get into it
what are i-bonds
i-bonds are savings bonds produced by
the u.s government that earn an interest
rate based on combining a fixed rate
with the inflation rate the fixed rate
is pretty low right now in fact it's
0.00 percent but the inflation rate
which is set based on the consumer price
index is quite high at 7.12
that rate is reevaluated every six
months in may and november just one year
ago when my colleague jason zweig wrote
about ibons the rate was a measly 3.54
thanks to inflation it has more than
doubled and based on the way the cpi has
been moving over the past year or so the
next rate might be even higher ibons are
issued by the us treasury department and
pay interest over a 30-year period but
you can redeem them after as little as
one year with a small penalty they were
introduced in 1998 by former vice
president al gore as a way to save for
things like college and retirement and
to quote ensure that those savings are
never undercut by future inflation like
u.s treasury bonds savings bonds are a
loan to the federal government but
unlike treasury bonds you can't sell
them to other investors or hold them in
brokerage accounts and you can't buy
i-bonds from banks or brokers anymore
i-bonds can only be purchased on the us
treasury's website
treasurydirect.gov or through your tax
return if you want to buy the old school
paper [ __ ] that's a big reason why so
few people have heard of them i talked
to treasury spokesman john rizzo who
said there's no real advertising
campaign to tell the public about these
bonds outside of treasurydirect.gov
since they don't generate a profit for
anyone except the bondholders there
aren't any big advertising campaigns
and there are no plans to change that
even though most people have never heard
of treasurydirect.gov
through march the public held just 56
billion dollars worth of eye bonds
that's less than one quarter of one
percent of all u.s debt held by the
public for comparison about three
trillion dollars worth of 30-year
treasury bonds have been issued this
year getting a treasury direct account
can also be a bit of a hassle i tried
signing up and was told that because
their systems couldn't verify my
identity online i had to print out a
form and fill it out then i had to take
that form to a bank and have a
certifying officer confirm my identity
and then i had to mail it back to them
at which point my account could be
opened in 10 to 15 days but officials
also tell me the treasury department is
quote in the process of developing an
updated modern replacement for the
current treasury direct system so things
could be getting easier there is one
other catch you can only buy ten
thousand dollars worth of i bonds each
calendar year sorry mr hedge fund and
the ibund interest rate does fluctuate
with inflation so if prices cool down
your i bond interest rate will cool down
too but it will never fall below zero so
you can't lose money
when i think about i bonds i think about
the late great russell jones aka old
dirty bastard who said why wouldn't you
want to get free money i'll see you next
time